to learn
so farmers can use precision agriculture
and so that seniors can access
telemedicine and so much more
better looks like removing lead pipes
cleaning up abandoned oil and gas wells
that dirty communities building 500 000
electric vehicle charging stations that
prepare us for our future
better looks like creating good paying
union jobs a top priority for this
president
the better is making it possible for
companies to manufacture more products
right here in america to build our
supply chains here so that americans can
get what they need
more efficiently and lower cost
better looks like using this investment
in our infrastructure and our people to
build more resilience and combat climate
change which threatens us all
and finally and most importantly
better looks like rebuilding america in
ways that move all of us forward with
equity at the center of everything that
we do so that no community and no person
is left behind because we are better
together and because diversity is this
nation's greatest strength
that is what building a better america
looks like
mr president your team has hit the
ground running
60 days in billions of dollars are
headed to the people of america through
the states local governments
territories and tribes
we're breaking down silos across
agencies this is a one-team one-fight
mission to build a better stronger
america
and since we haven't spent this kind of
money on infrastructure and generations
we're also talking about how to do it
with accountability making sure we can
be good stewards of the taxpayers
dollars and deliver results on time on
task and on budget
mr president with this cabinet and the
partners we have on the state and local
level with community leaders and the
people of this great nation we are up to
the challenge
it won't be easy
nothing worth doing if ever is so mr
president you set a very high standard
but we're going to put our shoulder to
the wheel and we're going to get it
for our beloved country
thank you please welcome the president
of the united states
well thank you uh very much mitch it is
uh
there's a lot of talk about uh
disappointments and things we haven't
gotten done
we're gonna get a lot of them done i
might add
but
this is something we did get done
that's of enormous consequence to the
country
one of the reasons i put mitch landrieu
in charge of uh implementing the
infrastructure bill
is because he gets it
he's a former mayor who knows that the
real measure of success is not did we
score some partisan points
it's did we fix the problem
did we fix the problem
this is all about fixing the problem i
ran for president to unite the country
this bipartisan infrastructure law i
signed
two months ago unites us around
things we all depend on
whether you're in rural kentucky or
downtown philadelphia you should be able
to turn on a faucet and drink clean
water
students
should be able to get the internet if
they needed to do their homework at home
instead of having to drive to a park
fast food parking lot
people need good jobs
mitch has told me about the man he met
in jackson mississippi you told him
quote i don't mind working three jobs i
just don't want one paycheck across all
three jobs
you know we've heard it said
talent is equally distributed but
opportunity is not when we invest in
infrastructure we're really investing in
opportunity
these are investments that
will build a better america sounds like
hyperbole but it's real so today i want
to talk about the progress we've made in
two months since i signed the bill into
law
and to make a big announcement as well
here's some of what we've done so far
the department of transportation has
released nearly 53 billion dollars
billion dollars to states to modernize
highways
so you have to leave 30 minutes earlier
to get to work just because of a traffic
jam that's going to be fixed
we've announced more than 240 million in
grants to improve ports in 19 states to
speed up and strengthen our supply
chains lower cost and get you the things
you need more quickly
we've announced 3 billion dollars
for over 3 000 airports around the
country to make them more modern safe
and sustainable
and we're kicking off the largest
investment and affordable reliable
high-speed internet in our nation's
history
65 billion dollars to get to every
corner of our country connected urban
rural and suburban
our infrastructure work also protects
health cleans up the environment and
helps us fight climate change
across this country people have been
struck
and they
and they've been struck by all the
changes that are needed
they're stuck they're angry they're
sickened by the broken water and sewer
systems polluted water from the faucets
raw sewage in
i
their
backyards
to know i see you i hear you we
understand
and i've seen and we've understand the
damage done in places like flint
michigan and jackson mississippi
so we've already announced over seven
billion dollars in clean water funding
to states so they can fix and upgrade
their aging water systems and sewer
systems
it's gonna take some time but the
money's there and they're getting the
money
our children deserve no less
we've also released an action plan to
replace all of our nation's lead pipes
in the next decade
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
everyone in this country should be able
to turn on the faucet and drink clean
water
and it's time to get back to the
business of cleaning up the hazardous
waste sites that poison our land and
water and have stricken entire
communities
and getting back to holding polluters
accountable to keep that pollution from
happening in the first place
the environmental protection agency has
announced
one billion dollars to clean up 49
superfund sites in 24 states
we're talking about cleaning up rivers
in ohio chemical plants and sites in
florida polluted lakes in michigan and
many more
this is long overdue we have to stick
with it the department of interior is
launching the program to cap and plug
orphaned oil and gas wells
that are spewing methane into the air
and are dangerous
many of these wells are in southwestern
pennsylvania and eastern ohio
but there are hundreds of thousands of
them all across the nation
capping them is going to create quality
jobs
just as it took to dig the well
union jobs union jobs to close the well
to keep it safe
one of the ways we're going to reach my
goal of 100 carbon pollution free
electricity by 2035 is with wind energy
i visited one of the renewable energy
labs in colorado about a month ago and
saw technologies being developed there
and just this week the department of
interior also announced the largest ever
offshore wind lease sale
which could generate enough clean energy
to power nearly 2 million homes and
create thousands of jobs in
manufacturing construction operations
and maintenance it's just the beginning
jobs that can't be outsourced we've also
seen the impact of extreme weather
taking down transmission lines leaving
cities and communities dark for weeks so
the department of energy launched a new
initiative to speed up our efforts to
strengthen our energy grid with new and
upgraded transmission lines and towers
keeping the power flowing
for americans with cleaner cheaper and
more reliable energy
and that's going to happen
it's going to make a big difference
i also want to be clear
we're in this to win
and you know there's there's there's a
lot of work underway
it's going to create a whole lot of jobs
and that brings me to the announcement i
want to make today it's just part of the
infrastructure bill my bipartisan
infrastructure law includes the largest
investment in our nation's bridges since
the creation of the interstate highway
system
bridges to connect us bridges to make
america work
across our country right now there are
45 000 bridges 45 000 that are in poor
condition
we're seeing photos of some of them
behind me in all 50 states
and i've had a chance to see some of
them myself as i've traveled the country
it was up in new hampshire visited a
bridge where if it's not upgraded weight
restrictions could mean that school
buses and fire trucks would have to
travel an additional 10 miles out of the
way to get to the other side of the
river to deal with getting to school and
or putting out a fire
in new jersey i just visited the busiest
rail bridge in the western hemisphere
but because it's not tall enough
for ship traffic it needs to swing open
to let barges through
and sometimes when it closes the rails
need to be manually sledge hammered back
into place
this slows commerce increased cost
i went down to louisiana and saw the
i-10 bridge i stood at the mayor and
looked at that bridge
it's 20 years past its landline it's
handling more than double the number of
crossings it was designed to handle
and it's two lanes narrower than the
interstate that feeds into it causing
backups and accidents
today the secretary of transportation
pete bootages in philadelphia at the
martin luther king bridge which crosses
the schoolkill river
the bridge is no longer safe for
vehicles even though it used to carry 25
000 vehicles a day
as we prepare to celebrate dr king's
birthday we're also reminded that too
often bridges and highways were built
through the heart of historic
communities particularly black
communities
cutting off families churches and
businesses we're going to use our
infrastructure investments to reconnect
communities
one thing i'm certain of
everyone out there knows what i'm
talking about
people have written me about bridges
they depend on one man told me that the
bridge he traveled on every day is a
tragedy waiting to happen
one woman wrote that a bridge near the
center of her town
had to be closed
and now she drive now drivers and
tourists bypass downtown consequently
devastating local businesses
and one person wrote to me to say quote
this is your chance to show the people
in my area that they matter to you end
of quote
i hear you
i hear you you do matter to me and we
are going to get it done my
infrastructure law includes a total of
40 billion dollars in funding for bridge
improvements
12.5 billion of that is going to replace
most the most economically significant
bridges in the country these are bridges
like and i've seen them
the brent spence bridge
connecting ohio and kentucky
the i-5 columbia river crossing
connecting washington and
oregon you know the uh the blattneck
bridge connecting minnesota and
wisconsin
but about two-thirds of the bridges in
need of repair
in this country are considered what they
call off-system because they're not
directly connected to the interstate
highway system
these are the bridges are often
overlooked
when decisions are being made but they
are essential for small towns rural
towns farmers to get their products to
market small businesses to be able to
serve customers
these are the bridges that when they're
closed
shut off deliveries and
routes to school work and home
they create longer delays for first
responders when every second counts
so we've included
27.5 billion
for smaller bridges including dedicated
funding for those off system bridges i
just described
and because maintaining these bridges is
often the responsibility of counties or
towns whose budgets are stretched thin
already we decided to get rid of the
requirement
that counties or towns share in the cost
the federal government is going to pay
for 100
of the cost for repairing these small
bridges
today we're releasing the first year of
that program which is 5.5 billion
dollars
five and a half billion dollars to
states and tribes repair and rebuild
bridges to make them safer and more
usable
this is an investment that's going to
help connect entire towns and regions to
new opportunities
with this investment we're sending the
message to those communities and the
people who call them home
you matter
we're building back and building back
better with you
we're making sure you're not left behind
and left out
align with this
these investments are consequential
we're just getting started
we're building back better than ever
before
clean water for every american
we've never done that before
now we're going to do it high-speed
internet for every american we've never
done that before now we are
connecting forgotten communities capping
wells that are dangerous strengthening
our power grid to make it more resilient
to extreme weather changes
these are investments these are
investments our country has never fully
made
now we are
you know and we've arrived at this by a
bipartisan agreement
there's nothing beyond our capacity when
we work together
when we get this done
we'll get back to beating the world
again
we've once again been number one in the
world
instead of where we sit now at number 13
in terms of the quality of our
infrastructure
that's going to mean more jobs
good paying jobs
safer communities
lower costs
we can do this
this is what america better america is
going to look like i want to thank you
all for listening and we've got a lot of
work to do and the reason i ask mitch mc
to do this
is because he knows how to get things
done i want every penny watched how this
is spent
just like when i did the recovery act in
our the last administration it matters
it matters so thank you all very much
appreciate it
[Music]
you